[Music]
you are watching the
press preview a first look at what's on
the front pages as
they arrive in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines with the
journalist and author
rachel shabby and the columnist at the
article ali
mirage so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
the sunday telegraph reports that the
health secretary
took three days to tell the prime
minister about a key study showing the
effectiveness of vaccines against the
delta variant of the virus
more than 50 tory mps are backing plans
for a pandemic law aimed at
blocking future lockdowns that's on the
front of tomorrow's sunday
express the sunday people says the tuc
is lobbying to have long covert classed
as a disability
john burko the former tory mp and
speaker of the house of commons
announces he switched
his political allegiance to labour
that's on the front of the observer
while the sunday times says that the
treasury is concerned at boris johnson's
uncosted spending announcements
and says the chancellor and the pm could
be headed for a showdown
the mail on sunday claims prince charles
has made it clear to the duke and
duchess of sussex
that archie will never be a prince under
his plans to limit
the number of key royals
let's turn now to uh rachel and ali to
take us
through some of those stories on the
front pages uh good evening to both of
you let's um
start off with uh this story that we
started that that rundown of what's in
the newspapers with
the front page of the telegraph and matt
hancock seemingly
withholding uh information from the
prime minister
rachel well yes that's right it seems
uh as though somebody or rather multiple
stories of
multiple sources according to this
telegraph story
are now throwing health secretary matt
hancock under the bus
by revealing as they are in this piece
that
he had public health england information
uh about the effectiveness of the
vaccine
in controlling the delta variant
of the virus he had that three days
before
uh the meeting in which boris johnson
and senior cabinet members decided to
delay uh the next phase of easing
lockdown measures
uh which was dubbed freedom day
unfortunately and
unnecessarily by boris johnson um so
hancock had this information and didn't
disclose it now
to be fair to the situation um
it was by that stage according to many
scientists
that it would be a good idea to pause
uh further easing of lockdown just
because
uh variant has become dominant in the uk
uh cases are rising
the link has to some extent been broken
between infections and hospitalizations
thanks to the vaccine
but it hasn't been severed entirely
there are
hospitals and that's because there are
still people
who have not been um
vaccinated yet particularly young people
so it does make to wait a few weeks so
that we can actually just buy time
to get more people vaccinated this does
not in
any way let hancock off the hook
for competitive and utter failures
um in a situation where tens of
thousands of people
died who did not need to
failures around test and trace failures
around ppe
failures around failing to protect our
most vulnerable in elderly care homes
let's just bring let's just bring an ali
ali in on that
um ali the question i suppose is why
would would
matt hancock be withholding this uh
information
well we don't know jillian but it's been
quite a week for the health secretary
the week that uh
dominic cummings the former the uh the
prime minister's former
chief adviser released text messages
showing that the prime minister
branded uh matt hancock hopeless matt
hancock
to be fair to him uh doesn't believe
he's hopeless
as he's told us um but it is a bit odd
that
uh such an an important decision this uh
information was not revealed to the
prime minister on sunday
when he had a meeting when he got back
from the g7 summit
uh in downing street with members of the
quad including rishi sunat
and uh michael gove and hancock himself
that he wasn't made aware of this
it's this decision was on a knife ed
uh we we know that this week 49 tory
mps voted against the extension um
by a month to july because there is
increasing unrest on the tory back
benches not just from
the usual suspects of the covid recovery
group but that group now is expanding
out
to even careerist and loyalist tory mps
who feel deeply uncomfortable
about the fact that restrictions are
still imposed
and the implications of that's having on
the travel industry
on the entertainment industry and on the
freedom of
their constituents to go about their
daily business so i do think it's a
an issue and i do think that matt
hancock's gonna have to explain
why on what basis this information was
not
revealed to the prime minister last
sunday look rachel may be right that in
reality it may not have made the
difference
but it should have been revealed at that
point when such a critical decision was
going to be made
well what's your gut feeling ali is it
incompetence or
or is there reasoning behind this
information not being
shared what what do you feel
look i think matt hancock has to answer
uh that question
i know that he's had a very difficult
period um over the last 15 months to be
fair to him
it was it's been an unprecedented
situation and he's also been
working extremely hard and doing his
best there have been a number of
missteps along the way but this is a
very very sensitive time matt hancock
knows the
pressure that the government is under to
open up fully uh we are moving in the
right direction we know that this uh
extension to the uh to the restrictions
buys us a bit more time to get
the first jab stats up even even further
and the second jab stacked up
as well um but it uh he has to really
explain why i
really don't know uh julian i can't
answer
no of course she can't because you're
not meant hancock uh let's move on to
the um
observer and on their front page this
story uh with john perko
photographed he has decided to join
the labour party and has had some pretty
damning things to say about um
the government and uh boris johnson
ali oh sorry uh sorry sorry julian yes
uh well john burko
uh a lot of stories would be saying this
evening well good riddance sir they're
surprised it took him this long
i mean john burke has been on a journey
since the 1980s when he was a student
uh john burke was a member of the
right-wing monday club that wanted to
repatriate
immigrants um who moved to the uk so now
he's sort of become this
uh let it all hang out sort of liberal
uh labor right
uh and he's been he's been sympathetic
to the labour party for many years he's
been on a
personal philosophical journey and i
don't think any stories will be
shedding any tears for john berko
particularly as he was the most partisan
speaker
that we've seen in generations and the
first speaker indeed not to be offered
appearing
since 1761. so i don't think anyone's
going to be particularly upset about
this john burko
is passionate about certain things he's
been on a journey and i think he's ended
up in his rightful place which is
uh in the labour path rachel your
thoughts were you surprised
i think it's really interesting when
conservatives like john
donbarco make this switch because it
shows you how much the
conservative party has changed it really
has radicalized
right um elements like um
you know not respecting parliamentary
democracy not respecting the judges
um you know undermining the judiciary
these sort of
behaviors we've seen from the
conservatives i know people don't like
to hear
this of the party that support but it is
these are authoritarian
measures and so it's interesting to see
that there are conservatives who do
identify that
and clock that and say you know what
that's no longer for me
i want to prevent this further slide of
this party now in government
to the right ali moving on to the
times front page and it seems as if the
chancellor
and the prime minister are heading
towards some sort of fiscal bust-up
according to the sunday times well yes
this is uh all about the fact that uh
there's real tension
uh and consternation the treasury that
the prime minister keeps
uh making all these uh spending
announcements about what he wants to do
without checking
anything off with the treasury i mean we
know that there are
uh the g7 summit he was making
announcements about
uh a new green marshall plan all sorts
of commitments on
pop 26 on decarbonization the
decarbonization agenda
uh he also wants to build this uh new
yacht for 200 million
pounds and we know that the prime
minister is used to having his cake and
eating it
but ultimately the chancellor has to
foot the bill and the chancellor is one
of the few people in the government
who's actually shown
that he's competent so he's clearly very
worried about this now where is this
money going to come from
rishi tsunak faces a 2 trillion pounds
of public debt
350 billion pounds of borrowing this
year he's looking at things like
pensions this triple lock
which if it's broken and this is this is
where you know pensioners get the higher
of
2.5 average earnings or inflation um
this could this could save four four
billion pounds and so rishi sunak is
looking at that
because he's been boxed in by pledges
that were made in the manifesto to not
increase
income tax not touch capital gains tax
he has looked at corporation tax we know
that that is going up from
19 to 25 percent but in in the coming
years by 2023
but he's got very limited room for
fiscal maneuver and this is
this is seriously an issue that is
worrying the treasury
and the prime minister needs to be
speaking to his chancellor and be locked
step with him because
we can't afford fiscal profligacy we
need to be very careful
we've got a recovery to manage here and
we can't let debt completely balloon out
of all
troll yes uh and rachel the the papers
are reporting that
the chancellor's chancellor's concerned
that uh borrowing more johnson's
preferred solution to the cash crunch is
dangerous because
rising inflation is likely to result in
an increase in interest rates which is
uh extremely important
uh well rishi sunak has is by his own
admission
uh fiscal conservative he just said as
much in the last few days
broadcast interviews it's no surprise
boris johnson likes to spend but it's
worth pointing out that he doesn't
really understand
uh the economic reality we're in either
his version of spend is
you know ill-conceived freeports fantasy
bridges and royal
it's interesting um that we heard the g7
reference just now the
joe biden administration hardly left
wing pretty centrist pretty moderate
outfit is urging the uk and other
countries to spend
right now so they have broken from
the old and now un outdated and
not relevant to this time concept of
fiscal conservatism they've identified
it as completely
ineffective to deal with the reality
that we're in
and they're urging companies to defend
rachel we must
leave it there sadly we have run out of
time we shall see
you in the next hour both yourself and
uh ally
oh actually we are taking a break i'm
running ahead of myself uh see you after
the break
uh coming up families receive huge bills
in the wake of the grenfell tragedy as
the government attempts
to crack down on buildings with unsafe
cladding
[Music]
and what we found is that one in five
jobs
nearly six million highly skilled people
uh work in what we call anywhere jobs
these are jobs that can be done fully
remotely from home
but they can also be done anywhere in
the world potentially for cheaper
these jobs tend to typically be well
paid in the tech sector
finance professional services and
because they can be done fully remotely
they are
vulnerable a bit to outsourcing and
offshoring
as firms look to cut costs and boost
productivity as they bounce back from
pandemic
so the profile of the individual we're
looking at is typically
younger relatively well paid tends to
have a degree
be a parent with some dependent children
live in london and southeast so these
are relatively high skilled
individuals working in what would
otherwise be good careers
and their jobs can be done fully
remotely but also that makes them
vulnerable and that contrasts to the
past where
it's typically more routine
manufacturing clerical jobs that were
vulnerable to
automation and globalization in the 80s
and 90s
what we're seeing now is a trend where
remote work is really a possibility and
an offshoring is really a possibility
for these well-paid white-collar jobs
and i think there are probably three
specific things where
we look for the government to do to make
sure that
we can capture and keep remote workers
here and attract them from abroad i
think the first thing that they can do
is looking at the support systems the
infrastructure so this is not just
you know it includes connectivity and
high-speed broadband but it's also
things like child care so remote workers
can really work from
anywhere in the uk they want to i think
the second thing is rethinking the skill
system so that
every worker has both the softer
interpersonal skills
and the digital skills they need to
thrive in a tech based economy
and i think the third thing that we're
calling on the government to do is to
renew rethink the social contract uh so
that
it's adapting and keeping pace with a
more mobile more flexible labor market
in in a tech-enabled world
i'm siobhan robbins skies southeast asia
correspondent
in bangkok
[Music]
we are at a breaking point and we need
to work
now and fast even though young people
are vulnerable
to the importance of climate change
young people can also become the change
agents that we need to address
the climate impact in my campaign or in
advocacy work i work
largely with young people so that their
voices can be heard so they can also
influence
decision making from the local level to
the national level and thankfully
we are making progress in a regard
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me journalist and
author rachel shabby
and congress at the article ali mirage
let's take a look at this story in the
times it's the front page of the times
and it's uh
reporting on the the cladding scandal
and the the bills that many uh people
are having to face in order to make
their their properties safe i mean
you know a hundred thousand pounds is
the the sum
pictured on the front page ali
yeah i mean it's a huge story jillian i
mean it's four years since the grenfell
uh fire which uh induced all this uh
review of cladding and it is an
important issue of course
um but the people who have now been
stuck with the footing the bill of all
this
are the actual owners of these
properties who bought these properties
these flats in good faith
and are facing in some cases in many
cases about one-fifth that's been
reported in the
in the sunday times are facing
bankruptcy others are
facing mental health issues and this all
revolves around these
ews one forms that you have to now
procure
to actually even get a mortgage or
re-mortgage your
flat uh you can't sell it unless you can
get this ew
s1 form you're in the hands of the fire
brigade to give you
uh an opinion on this it's causing a lot
of lot of
mental health issues and serious concern
out there and people having to pay
thousands of pounds for waking watches
where people patrol
or day and night these buildings um to
try and do this the government's only
helping
buildings above 18 meters below that
you're on your own basically
and it's a real scandal i think it's a
huge issue
and the government needs to do more it
hasn't done enough on there yes these
people are in dire straits
as reported there the um heartbreaking
stories actually to the mail
just got time to finish off on this one
rachel uh the headline there charles
won't let
archie be a prince talk us through this
story
um well you know i'm probably not the
best person to talk us through this
story it seems that prince charles wants
to ensure that
um his two-year-old grandson archie
won't
ever be uh won't ever be
um on the throne they're trying to
streamline
the royal family have less people in
line to the throne
i mean you know i think the royalty is
anachronistic
and you know out of date so
if there's if there are a few of them in
line to the throne i mean
i don't really have a lot to say about
that to be honest
well ali the the piece is basically
saying that um
harry megan's son will have no place
amongst frontline royals as he plans a
slimmed down
monarchy um would you prefer to see a
slim down monica ali
to be honest with you i would have been
more than happy to see harry continue to
play his role i thought he
he added a lot of value to public life
but he's a he's a free citizen he's
decided to
um he i thought he wanted a quiet life
with megan when he went to canada
the next thing we know that he's turning
up as a woke celebrity with his wife on
talking to oprah and recording all sorts
of podcasts
there's that word again woke i'm gonna
ban it from the uh
press preview rachel
thank you so much we'll see you in the
next hour